again I'm sorry I'm back in but it's
been a few years that I spoke about
physics to anyone this was one of the
things that I was working on when I was
in grade 11 which tries to understand M
is M naught divided by one minus square
root of 1 minus v square by C square the
equation that led Einstein to discover
is equal to mV MC squared I try to work
out other possible equations that I
could derive out of it and one
interesting thing I was working on was
in trying to understand what happens to
mass at speed of light which I believe
must completely converts into ether
which is energy ok so you see here M is
M naught blah blah blah this is what I
got to em I am NOT is e naught minus 2 K
so this is the ratio between mass in
motion and mass at rest is equal to
ratio between energy at rest- to kinetic
energy / energy in motion now energy at
rest and energy in motion is I
understand it is my creation and and
nothing of that sort exists question
number one are these valid can I assume
he not and eat question number two thus
this equation make any sense because if
it does I would like to work on this in
trying to understand how does matter get
converted into energy with with gradual
ascent in in acceleration all the weight
and speed of light thank you so much
thank you
you